have you ever thought about wrapping
what made you actually that here side
this is not for me I am on the 13th yeah
I need it when the rapper's raided you
did you feel more hurt
[Music]
it's off the Leonard defended by Simmons
is this the tiger
[Music]
[Applause]
the big storyline during the playoffs
now has kind of been like what's Tamar
thinking watching the Raptors playing so
what is damar thinking um the guys say
like my best friend is Kyle so I'm
rooting for my best right you know to do
well to accomplish something that we
tried to do all the years and he has the
opportunity I do it it's all guys on
their team
they know you know I'm rooting for I
know them now this narrative is like
they couldn't get there with damar they
could only get there now because they
have Kauai
what is your response to that honestly I
don't even think I said this I probably
said this month my inner circle but for
wasn't for all the years and groundwork
that I did before then none of the
things would've been possible yes I
fought our sacrifice I pushed the limits
to where I would be the sacrificial lamb
you just have to sit back and understand
like you know you are the reason so many
things was even possible
today traitor they probably felt like it
was time to see what we can get to make
that next jump when the Raptors traded
you did you feel more hurt or more angry
not hurt because you know being invested
from 19 to I was 28 you know everything
you learned was from there every day and
you gain was from there so for that to
be going like that when you least expect
it it just throws you off guard
you know we human at the end of Danny
and then definitely at you now you are
in San Antonio playing with the Spurs
most importantly plans for Popovich pop
is cool he's like a Don Corleone you
know he makes you look at him not just
like the basketball coach but like you
know a great individual and I called him
another day used to talk talk trash song
and he's not good with working the high
phones and I like like he hate
technology to a passion so he always
talked about he gonna put some on
Twitter like knowing hand got a Twitter
like no he called a Twitter gram I'm
gonna put some on Twitter ground me see
this give me an example of something he
educated you guys on in a meeting
I remember one meeting I'm thinking
watch film he put on a penguin movie it
was like the whole thing from you know
having a baby to the male carrying the
egg to the women go out fish for food
bring back the food two months later
penguins walk 90 miles with the egg the
whole point of it was how life is a full
circle you know and how we all as long
as we work together and stick together
and stay on the same track how we can
accomplish the most impossible mission
I remember reading he will spend tons of
money on team dinners throughout the
season mandatory
he called it break bread win lose or
draw out their game if we stand over in
City we got a team dinner we're gonna
break bread we're gonna have a good
night of the evening you know we're
family
let's go buy some shoes Guinea so this
is spot is it is it like heaven
it's everything this is my go-to spot
you come in here there's a lot of shoes
where do you start
sometimes I think about my favorite
Jordans which ones I don't have I can't
cry and then I come in here and look for
him yeah see what they got
which Jordan stick out to you up here
what Jordans to me I feel like probably
these shattered backboards what about
those what makes I don't think I have
these
how many sneakers do you have the real
number that's the great question I
planned a different shoe every single
game so I probably go through at least a
hundred pair of shoes in the season
every single game I play a new shoe my
shoes at home it's definitely at a
couple hundred probably more than two -
sure more than four yeah more than 600
probably up there for sure are there any
shoes that like take you to a specific
memory or specific game when you look at
him these were the faint Jordans I had
13 with the jump man the other way and I
poked a hole in a bubble the Jordan was
fake everything like I think it's great
because I know you still loved him oh
yeah I'm warm too they had a hole in
illiterate ease I like these I might get
these you just no no no yeah I know my
feet no now when you say that you wear a
new shoe every game do you mean new
never been worn never been worn
brand new okay explain why I don't tie
my shoes when I play I like I do not
lace my shoes at all I like my shoes
tight fit so when a brand new
they fit my feet perfectly so once I
played my shoe broken into I'm done with
them shoes neither new one next game
what size she were you 13 do you guys
have this in the 13 hey side this is not
for me I am NOT a 13th yeah I need it if
you got it for me I walk around 13 I
hope and unfortunately well I'm happy I
know when I get I don't think it's over
here I think it's over here is okay take
a look okay I have every Kobe in the
world you really have every single
coffee - yeah I have every single Kobe
soo talk to me about what Kobe has meant
to you because I know that's a very like
key figure in your basketball life Cole
was somebody I just gravitated to and
always rooted for I remember his right
here when he's a when he played in Utah
any air ball all them threes and
non-member everybody killing them in oh
no I just remember being emotional as a
kid like Dan why are you doing that what
are you doing man like this is my
favorite player and it just grew over
time to where that was my favorite
player so being able to have a
relationship will so be able to play
against them now Kobe of course was a
Laker do you ever have any dreams of
playing in LA I think you be crazy so
you never want to play home everybody
always want to have that opportunity but
I think I'm definitely happy where I'm
at and I watch them from a distance what
do you love more shoes or music you have
to pick don't say both music
really yeah music yeah I think for me I
need that concert new music of something
you can relate to you need it you made
it for every any type of move why'd you
listen to you on your way to the
interview nips we've seen Pepsi yes oh
no
whatever just new rotation
grammy-nominated rapper and community
activists in tipsy hustle was murdered
in broad daylight outside a clothing
store that he owned in South Los Angeles
and he was killed just before he was
about to meet with city leaders and the
LAPD about reducing gang violence what
made him so special to you I grew up in
Compton roughest of the rough to us
coming from the urban area you know we
seen a guy like nipsey start from
nothing you know he was on motivation he
was a different type of life for us that
we could we could relate to we
understood and it's a lot of people I'm
close to that still lived there people
getting killed people again it's so much
of that reality that's my reality
the crazy thing I'm thinking about two
three weeks before it had dinner with
him we had the most in-depth
conversations about you know life about
how to be a better individual how to you
know give back how to make sure your
people straight a plan to do something
great that's something that's always
gonna and all mistake stay close to me
for sure because I remember that night
like like it was yesterday
so have you ever thought about rapping
what made did somebody tell you them I
just want to know the answer this is I'm
asking you this this another exclusive
now I'm gonna say here on your show only
people close to me no no notice but I
have like a album slash mixtape tell me
about this
man you know last two summers honestly
I've been thinking about like just
leaking this song and see what happened
okay tell me one lyric you've read one
lyric Oh what something I'm trying to
find any way to get out of this right
now
I ain't gonna lie I was just trying to
make up some bleach report they go no
your rap okay if you had to pick a
rapper I'm not saying you sound like
them but you think that your sound is
maybe similar I don't know it's just me
my you know West Coast Conference I
don't know I've gotten Ice Cube okay I
don't had a few of my rapper friends
like kind of compliment me so he gave me
a little bit more confidence
what rappers have come up in any music
I'll let kendrick hear one of my songs
for alleged right here you bother having
me go viral about being on it's gotta be
great god it's gonna be so I thought the
day would come then is that Megan my
ringtone we only get tagged in so much
stuff what would Drake's critiques of
your rap I was at one of the shows he
played in them back everybody was back
there and played it and everybody only
his he only he knew it was me yeah wait
but so everyone's listening to it they
know is you but they like the song I
feel good oh it's cool with that like my
dog nobody else need to hear this I'm
cool
now in 2018 you publicly acknowledge
depression by tweeting this depression
gets the best of me when it gets the
best of you what does that look like
know everything just build up in one you
know you kind of shut yourself out from
everything and a lot of people don't
understand you know and you kind of to
be around a group of people and still
feel alone what was going on for you
personally at that moment that you sent
that tweet I think it was overwhelming
of everything when I tweeted out with
all-star weekend in LA and being in LA
being a starter on the all-star team
I'm just decided to get home when I see
my kids when a chill everything just
became so overwhelming you know and I
just had that moment you know I turn to
Twitter which is the devil so when you
sent it though you're like okay this
feels good yeah I didn't think men other
than what have I done now I got to deal
with this head-on so anytime I'm doing
an interview I always try to ask people
that know my guest about them and what
they would ask them what they think of
the person so when I asked Kevin Love
about what you have meant to his life
this is what he said to me
damar opened the door for me and at a
time I needed it the most I thanked him
and show love for him every time I see
him now it's more than just a hey I've
known you since high school brotherly
hello it's more of a you helped me out
of the darkness type of bond whether he
knows it or not
Kevin said that where were you I care
it's a hug for me to UK care of my man
like that meant a lot nobody never know
where we go through his athletes you
know so for me to open the door and my
selfish moment of feeling hi felt and
you know just saying [ __ ] i'ma just
go out and be straight up with with what
this for him looking at me and a light
like I help them out don't ya and for
the words that he used were so powerful
you got him out of a darkness if we
could do that for one another
imagine what we don't for everybody else
you know we just said in a tone for that
and we really doing something that's
really inspiring it's definitely cool
what helps you now get through
depression my two daughters send the
greatest example for them the light that
they look at me in is like I'm Superman
but that I'm back in my mind and
everything I do it makes it easy to be
motivated to push to go through the pain
to go through the tough times
understand how to be better you know for
them there's no beating that yeah I see
it for me hey guys i'ma do a bar you do
a bar you don't have to be sorry well
okay
in the interview learn he don't drink
booze we in the car going to buy some
shoes tailor check out the show when
every drop album coming maybe maybe not
I'm glad honored that I could end off
the season I appreciate everybody
watching absolutely hello guys it is
Taylor rooks thank you so much for
watching my show take it there but now
you have to subscribe you don't want to
miss the next interview and all the fun
stuff we're doing on the YouTube channel
so hit that subscribe button thanks see
you guys soon